[Musica]
ufficiale il portogallo che ripetere
balla balla allora oggi andremo a fare
lo slime condotta
beh però di te non mi interrompere avete
un affare da flame con troppi
ingredienti per questo io sono un master
che brandisce infatti sarà super
divertente se vi ricordate lo abbiamo
già fatto altre volte
in un altro episodio foto lo slate
propri ingredienti qui ho messo troppa
schermo da barba ed è uscita una specie
di sky gigante più afoso poi ho messo
troppa neve fin vendere un super
sembrava tifo una granita e fuori da un
botto con il clay con troppo place non
avete visto la fine di questo video vi
lascio il quadratino così potete andare
a vederlo la super divertente cosa volta
andremo a farne modo un po diverso
perché guadagnini ruota veramente la
mini ruota famiglie ora è il mio momento
qua gli ingredienti che possono capitare
mi sono allora abbiamo glitter lo con la
griffe rata fishbones lasci la libia
perline colorate e qui abbiamo unicorni
e code di sirene immerse quello per il
punto di domanda vuol dire che possiamo
scegliere noi un bar divertente per un
sacco di ingredienti
fateci sapere nei commenti polia altre
challenge
che facciamo nei prossimi video online
se volete vedere con tre episodi di slam
con troppi ingredienti mettetevi con
motivi di a tutto schermo è di the oc è
il primo round inizio io così in italia
bene perché non ha mai fatto con
tantissimi ingredienti allora vado a
girare la ruota quindi ha concluso mica
berlino punto di domanda
secondo me sono secondo me appunto di
domanda però effettivamente più po sul
punto di domanda che su perlina vediamo
più sul punto di domanda dove aprì
allora io scelgo sono contenta con le
perline comunque siamo comunque le
perline con acqua e proprio farlo già in
contanti
per cui davide mi dirà bene bene poi non
farle tutte che melo piace allora
facendo la cosa trasparente perché così
si vedono meglio le perline
vediamo un po certamente ora vado subito
non so se iniziare subito a mettere anzi
prima l'ottimo un pochino che è un
pochino attivo non del tutto però un po
inizio ad aggiungere filettati vivere
allora le perline che oggi ammette il
servizio all in cui abbiamo fatto
sopprima manzone da tiger tutti gli
assessori slime poi andate a vederlo
abbiamo preso questo per livio
bellissimo perché tutti i tantissimi
colori quindi con il libero sarà bustier
e così tanto live costantino così che
bravo secondo la signora dipenderà come
la tv the hook e belle arti colori
brizzi su queste dive per cui diventa il
bellissimo super colorato quale si
stanno formando un po le bolle purtroppo
quindi si vedranno un po di bollicine
però poi si schiarisce e sarà utilissimo
perché siamo poc'anzi vediamo che i
fischi cisco domenica prato animare
voglio proprio vedere anche cosa ti
capita dopo allora ecco lo slime e le
colline pensavo fossero un po di più
forse perché ho messo troppa colla
quindi non sono tantissime per un
effetto mi piace tantissimo perché il
super colorato e ora comunque lo slime
ha un sacco di bolle l'open trasparente
ma non appena diventerà nuovamente
trasparente si vedrà ancora meglio il
colore delle berline e bellissimo sempre
161 di carnevale con tutte le
decorazioni di colore migliore lo
lasciamo un pò riposare vediamo dopo
come diventa che sono si schiarirà
subito però poi vediamo come diversa per
ora like mi piace tutta adesso sentiamo
lo stare perché ha detto che è stato
usato
speri che ti capiti non lo so però che
io voglio fare il taxi slime quindi
probabilmente e cliccano sono quelli che
mi piacciono di più parlare dei 15 è
uscito che parola di allora quando di
scegliere alle col le palle colorate a
questa qui è anche se personale niente
ride e così decidiamo che averle tutte e
viola il violino solista di vedere come
diventano se stesse con dm del viola
sono quello di più perché mi deve fare
un colore più forte mettiamo 4 vetta
marrone non può diventare manovra che
deve dimettere school simboleggiante e
ma non è sicuro è però devi essere più
calda xvi
vedremo vedremo vedremo vi mettiamo poco
di questo pr fucsia raschia mettiamo un
po di rosa fucsia timori però mischiati
sia qualcos'altro ma che sono bellissime
poi dobbiamo mettere solo con un poco di
giallo in poco con l
no quale stelle vediamo perché si metta
a me perché mi avete fatto gialla
mettiamo solo poco cioè non so che è
vero
diverse le mettiamo due perché secondo
me ci sta bene assi ai dai sono curioso
di vedere come di meta e andiamo subito
a vedere
allora adesso posso già girarlo
giustamente vediamo perché mi sa che il
grosso
mi sai che sono io a roma
no adesso si deve amalgamare ancora con
i viola che diventano un po carlino
appoggiamo un po e un po un po
io corro china ma stavolta preparati
parlo vediamo qui diventa e coca cola
scaduta e marrone alzamora che ha capito
qualcosa di quello che ha detto spesso
troppo bicarbonato
[Applauso]
ed è caduto un occhio perché il
bicarbonato agli occhi è caduto a
chiederlo slide a giustificarsi con un
occhio etico si metta ogni tanto almeno
un cadranno di bollire perché
particolare molto chiaro e con slide di
vitale e mai
diciamo che proprio un po particolare
questo è un colore è speciale colore
modo speciale chiaro ancora cosa scaduto
la primavera di per torino è un'ottima
nomale però vedi che sono non mi sarei
aspettata che il risultato è che omaggia
madrid in mezzo il tuo gara per questo
giocava xvi da affidare ancora è tutto
elastico e suo zio è molto lucido e
molto lucido e motivante e militato io
direi che max l'aper bellissimo sono che
ha vissuto molto bene la pista mi sento
bene in questo periodo quindi che uno
degli date al mio di prima è affetto da
uno a dieci allora crimen i commenti a
questo ed 11 municipi della città c'è il
colloquio di venti si vede l'occhio il
tuo ritmo e più bello dal mio ma non
troppo perché nella clinica bellissimo
ha detto allora che devono dare in
continente appunto ho visto solo
influenzando
la ruota ma questo lei già fatto due
c'erano le varie bolle colorate con i
litri di demo rigirare ma come lo fa
mette così uno stile che questi qua devo
stare attenta a mettere meno colla
altrimenti non lo riempi per bene lo
slime pochettino ancora di più è un
bastardino resteranno benevento le
decorazioni allora eccola tutto settore
fiori tutti gli ricordi che così di
stile
vediamo un po come
come si vede sono glitterate quindi sono
stupende quartieri colpiti
poi ci sono anche le conigliette
innestano parlate che bello peccato
appunto che con la palla trasporti
bisogna aspettare prima che torni
trasparente che un gioco di squadra io
vado attivarlo ecco qua allora è ancora
un po pc cosa perché lo dobbiamo far
riposare un po comunque fa un sacco di
suoni e se non ci fossi tante
decorazioni e niente lo dobbiamo far
riposare un po così si asciuga un
pochino e non è più così tanto pc cosa
purtroppo non è ancora completamente
trasparente altrimenti vedrebbero bene
tutte le decorazioni studer appetito che
un ballo c'era con tutte le sirene ora
non lasciamo riposare è vitale andrà a
fare l'ultimo live
poi andremo rivederli bene
[Musica]
vista con i piccoli la come si chiamano
l'islam come si chiamano in italiano
allora inizia con la colla si ok è
piaciuto proprio bene certo adesso
voglio vedere come faccio ad attivarlo
carico guarda già bellissimo da chi
aveva un tasto slime mi riprendo e
afflitto più punti mediate con quella
con un po calcola scaduto giriamo e
giriamo gira molto bene
guardare più bello colorato però anche
questa un sacco di bolle scelto bene
questa volta ho sciato benissimo bisogna
aspettare che si schieri il cane cielo
anche attivato meglio dell'altra sera
proprio vero che grado di verde questo
per avere coraggio in un sacco di colore
verde che vi suoni che si diano una
gestori però lo voglio vedere una volta
che diventa trasparente si sarà stupendo
la miseria per bello allora adesso ora
adesso aspettiamo un paio di giorni
vediamo se diventano trasparenti pochi
giorni e poi ve li facciamo rivedere
così potrete scegliere se ho vinto io
ovviamente vitale siete pronti 32
ok ho passato un giorno vediamo un po
come sono diventate gli slide curate qua
sotto si è schiarito fa un bellissimo
effetto luminoso e come brilla però
soffre non si è ancora scritto bene però
insomma volevo farvi rivedere subito se
non passava troppo tempo guardate un po
come brilla
sembra un po glitter bomb voglio fare
una palina sia un po indirizzo ma in
effetti questo contenitore non era il
massimo perché un po di aria bassa
guardate come brilla bel po di sfori
quindi questo era quello di vita che si
è salvato è diventata un bel i
glitterball bella lucia tanti romani che
questo era quello di vitale e diciamo
che il colore non è cambiato è sempre
marroni
è un po un po deboli base l'occhio e
bollicine sono andate un po in
superficie eccolo qua praticamente
ass.to per il quale quasi un pochino
diventato trasparente ma non tanto forse
bisognava aspettare qualche giorno in
più che bello questo è il colore è
sempre brutto sia staccato l'occhio
sulla mano dove di quest ora lo sly
l'altro slime di vitale questo è un po
bruttino però è chiamato questo
mostriciattolo abbiamo qualche foto con
le decorazioni che purtroppo non si è
schiarito molto c'è un pochino qua sotto
ma sopra non tanto si vedono un po
meglio le decorazioni barocche 7 ed è
pieno di bollicine sopra perché appunto
si stava schiarendo ma si vuole ma ora
un po guardate vedete costa fosse
schiavitù che il figlio sembra che tutte
le decorazioni sono in acqua sommersa
nell'acqua sotto e invece sopra si
stavano creando appunto le bollicine
però sì bisogna aspettare ancora un
pochino magari voi lo faccio rivedere
tra qualche giorno però bello l'effetto
con tutte queste decorazioni in acqua
soprattutto l'acqua da lì sirena faccia
volte tante ipotesi si è allora poi
anche dall'altra sono emersi di
superficie che lo hanno eletto la mia
preferita
questa via mi piace questo ricordo e
infine abbiamo
quello con le berline allora tastierino
che questo non sia sparito del tutto
vedete tutte le cose sono salite quasi
per vice e qui sotto è molto più
trasparente vediamo un po come che figo
l'effetto è bellissimo non so perché mi
ricorda un budino morivano tipo che reca
nelle crowe sopra le sorprese e
bellissimo wow
questo quando diventerà completamente
trasparente sarà ancora più bello perché
ora non è completamente trasparente
vediamo provocare una sfera anche qua
qua un bellissimo cosa ne pensate
quali gli piace di più primo secondo
terzo quarto quello chi vince
soprattutto in volta la bellezza di
slide vitale allora scegliete in base
agli stand che mi sono piaciuti di più
se siete se vince e rita se vince vitale
votate quarne qua ho qua non mi ricordo
dalle partita votate nel sondaggio e ora
vi lasciamo qua quattro case l'irs cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
il caso su quello che preferite
no